Hey Youtubers it's Charlie this is going to
be my Gotham episode six video you maybe saw
some special things at the end of the episode
so just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet and don't worry we we
haven't seen the last of firefly for good
but she she might be under wraps for little
while the whole episode was about the dichotomy
between people like Gordon and Catwoman who
were all about the gray area Gotham to like
you can't be so extreme with the way you do
like justice the way you treat people and
you can't be so nutters that you just go off
the deep end like firefly this is Gotham sometimes
you gotta deal Batman's justice to get what
you need to the big antagonists the episode
were firefly who went completely nutters in
the episode even though they the sole kinda
want her to be sympathetic especially with
all those crazy experiments are going to be
doing honor in the Indian Hills Hospital the
Wayne enterprise zones what I think is going
on is there their driving Michael Chiclets's
character to one end of the spectrum so Gordon
being a hard ass doesn't seem bad like they
want Gordon to still seem like a good character
even though he's been the crap out of criminals
in the one Catwoman who is still committing
a lot of crimes to seem like a good character
when she's standing next to firefly who just
like full-blown jumps off the deep end starting
with number five though Butch gets a stump
on his hand this is one of the the more fun
parts the episode they they argue about what
to do with the blood he stop and Barbara appropriately
suggests that they go evil dead and given
the chainsaw and not really clear what Barbara's
been doing these last couple of episodes maybe
catching up on her horror films in between
having sex with Theo and Tabitha and trying
on different outfits the only thing I didn't
like about them giving them out like I love
they gave him a ballot but I was hoping that
he actually likes smash some people's heads
and like watermelons or something something
crazy especially after last week's episode
when they blew someone up with some C4 and
they really ended up throwing it away by the
end of the episode thingy which on the number
for everybody is treating everybody else like
complete shed Penguin is treating bushlike
should firefly's brothers treat her like shed
even Gordon is now treating people like shed
so the big arc of this first half of the season
is the reckoning that the order of St. Dumas's
bringing to Gotham if a reckoning is coming
to Gotham for Bruce Wayne that a reckoning
is probably coming for all these acyl characters
that are treating people like shed so Gordon
probably get a reckoning Michael Chiclets's
character is treating Gordon like shed probably
going to get a reckoning pain one is treating
bushlike should also gonna get a reckoning
the real question is is what form is that
going to take like last season Gordon already
got busted down to regular cop status so I
don't do the gonna do that again but I feel
like the obvious choice is to have Butch turn
on paying would like somehow break his conditioning
that was the whole idea I got of the levels
with Tabitha was supposed to be doing when
in actuality it really looks like she killed
him even though he showed up at the end of
the episode that that scene just didn't didn't
really work her outfit was definitely nice
to look at but really and it looked like she
was trying to kill him on the number three
though Catwoman and firefly steel a bunch
of money from human traffickers this is just
the show's way of telling you that even though
these two characters are criminals there still
people out there that are way way worse like
they don't want you to think of them as an
antagonist even though technically there villains
were gonna make him seem good because they're
stealing from people who are really terrible
selling women if firefly's character seemed
a little inconsistent to the episode like
it seem like she was going from 0 to 60 like
she's like this is really quiet flower was
really shy but the minute she puts her gear
on she turns into this dominatrix they're
just trying to convey her obsession with fire
think the same way heat wave on the flash
is obsessed with fire all of the actor the
place he weighed cells of the little bit better
than firefly did but to his credit he just
like a much a much more experienced actor
but if he didn't understand why Catwoman was
like was acting all weird when they were escaping
like she ran and she did like up a back flip
over that police car instead of just like
sliding over it are running around is because
they wanted Gordon to recognize her cat moves
in a like recognizer as Catwoman on the footage
that was kind of a set up for later even if
it was completely unnecessary if you are running
from police officers you insert back flipping
over everything you just use like run around
it but to be fair to the characters I feel
like the actors are playing this the way the
show is meant to be the show is meant to be
this heightened comic book reality that you
have a levels of reality that the most real
comic book show out there right now was daredevil
season one regular do this blind getting the
ship beat out of them trying to beat up other
criminals that you get the shows like the
flash that actually have people with superpowers
that metahuman's for the play little bit straighter
you know that you have the Cisco character
who is kind like the voice of the comic books
just calling things out and then you have
shows like Gotham that are almost like the
literal text of comic books like like they
were they played the way you would read a
comic book with certain types of jokes or
types of moments the best example of that
is when characters don't really act the way
natural people would act if you are in this
situation in like a little girl pulled a gun
on you you would probably just rush her Catwoman
scene where she dropped down and like she
took out all those hardened criminals that
that completely unrealistic remember this
is a comic book show so the actors are literally
performing as if they are in a comic book
I wouldn't call a camp but there is like some
energy from the 60s Batman TV show it can
be a little bit weird if you're used to watching
shows that play little bit more realistic
but on the number to a series of unfortunate
strangulation's starring the Riddler so he
and Ms. Kringle finally did the deed high-fives
high-fives all around good job to Riddler
for sale on the deal however he gets a little
bit crazy when Ms. Kringle admittedly makes
him into telling her about killing the police
officer all of her dialogue complete set up
but remember this is a comic book like work
we already know the outcome were trying to
get to the drama is in so much and him spilling
the beans it's and how he spills the beans
I feel like one of the most comic book things
that he's done all season is pull that badge
out see I totally kill them do you believe
me now like why is it so important Ms. Kringle
believe him that he killed that police officer
is it's almost like he's proud that he killed
him like he was waiting for her to give him
the opportunity to tell her even though he
kinda made it seem otherwise last season like
last season it was something he needed to
hide at all costs I just love just makes you
crazy but Ms. Kringle is in a coma now so
the question is is what's going to happen
when she wakes up will she wake up and turn
them into the police just add one more reckoning
to the scoreboard to be delivered at a later
date finally on my number one WTF moment Wayne
Enterprises the evil portion of Wayne Enterprises
has a secret research facility that's experimenting
on metahuman's or people they believed to
be metahuman's that's with the Indian Hills
facility was so I think is pretty obvious
what they're setting up here at some point
some of these criminals will break out like
they're just there teasing characters that
we haven't seen yet and I know some you are
trying to guess like who these characters
are they they haven't revealed all the comic
book characters are bringing on but I'm wondering
if Hugo strange is gonna rise out of this
group of people strange is more of a psychological
characters so he's tied more to Arkham storylines
but they haven't done as much with the Arkham
this year it seems like this is placed down
here is where the gonna be surfacing a lot
of their big big villains just because of
the relative ambiguity of of when Gotham takes
place in a time like that you know it's like
80s 90s technology but then they have some
things that are local or modern I think they
have a little bit more license with the way
they do characters that LiveWire for instance
like this this chick here I don't think this
is LiveWire because Supergirl on CBS is doing
LiveWire and I don't think that Warner Bros.
lets multiple versions of characters on shows
that we will probably see all of these characters
that the tease in future episodes so there's
something to be excited about is Gotham doing
full-blown metahuman's I do think that some
of them are metahuman's firefly however is
not the reason they think that she is is because
she's wearing that student protected her from
dying they think she is immune to fire if
it wasn't clear that suit melted to her skin
I don't they removed it but it might be bonded
to her now like I said earlier there there
trying to demarcate different types of dogs
you have your flat out antagonistic villains
like Theo even though he's kind of sympathetic
because what happened to his family and then
you have is really tragic characters like
firefly that are driven to crime by life of
abuse sometimes it can be really obvious which
characters the show wants you to root for
but they do that on purpose like they they
want you to see firefly and think of her as
a good character despite being completely
crazy let me know in the comments though what
you guys think about the firefly character
and when do you think that were gonna see
her again do you think it's going to be like
a couple more episodes or do you think that
will follow up with Indian Hills next week
partly kinda feels like vote just cut to her
in like three or four episodes after it's
been a couple weeks and I'll just let you
imagine what has been done her like the atrocities
and the doctors of committed experimenting
on her and don't forget Theo is now going
to be on the Wayne board so he's probably
going to gain access to these people funders
law the guy that Theo killed was kind like
the keeper of Wayne Enterprises dirty laundry
so Theo found out about all these things that
they were doing so he probably knows about
this place so hears was going on this new
episode of the flash tonight it is a couple
of the videos that I'm trying to get out but
up on price gonna do the flash next because
I'm some still moving it's getting a little
crazy I do want to do a new Supergirl video
there's a GNU trailer with footage of red
tornado in a couple new characters so be sure
to subscribe to get that hopefully that will
post by like Wednesday or Thursday the next
video I post that will be flash episode four
new firestorm what a coincidence that firestorm
version 2 is debuting the night after firefly
blows up and I know I said Gotham is like
the most comic book he show on TV right now
just because the characters act like they're
in a comic book Supergirl is like a little
more realistic than that but it exists, kind
of between the flash and got them in terms
of level of comic book Enis if that's an actual
word I just invented it will call call word
just in terms of reference material to give
you a picture of where where things are headed
like in terms of the tone Supergirl is riffing
more on the Richard Donner Superman film Superman
one in Superman to more than anything else
that a lot of the energy the comedy the pathos
is going to flow from where those Christopher
Reeves Superman's flow from white as way for
my new flash video to post tonight you can
click here to catch up with game of thrones
season six it is posted a new Ironborn video
yesterday and you can click here for all my
Supergirl videos I had done like four or five
Supergirl video so far thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five and I'll
see you guys tonight!